[Applaudissements]
c'est historique jean luc santini le
candidat soutenu par le président du
département est évincé dès le premier
tour de la municipale partielle dans son
fief à mantes la jolie après une
campagne tendue ce dernier totalise que
35 74% des suffrages s'il n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer pierre bédier a
réagi sur les réseaux le peuple a
toujours raison c'est le principe de
l'élection un seul voeu qu'il ait eu
vraiment raison seul l'avenir nous dira
si un ambitieux sans scrupules et dont
la nouvelle équipe découvrir à l'égoïsme
peut faire un élu jouant collectif et
dévoués au bien public et si toutes les
promesses individuelles et générales
seront tenues la suite au prochain
épisode
il n'y aura donc pas de second tour
puisque raphaël cogner obtient 51% des
voix c'est lui qui était soutenu par
pierre bédier en 2020 puis poussé vers
la sortie en janvier dernier s'émancipe
et prend sa revanche on est toujours
surpris quand on gagne dès le premier
tour parce que les montées sont
exigeants et donc ils vous donnent pas
leur confiance facilement donc oui c'est
une très grande fierté mais je sais que
cette victoire je la dois au travail que
j'ai fait mais aussi à toute mon équipe
donc je veux vraiment remercier tous les
habitants de mantes la jolie pour leur
confiance pour ce premier tour le taux
de participation s'est élevé à 42 49 %
c'est plus qu'en 2020 ou seulement 27,54
% des électeurs s'étaient déplacés aux
urnes pour les municipales
les autres candidats ont félicité le
nouveau maire avec peut-être résultat
c'est avant tout
d'une manière générale bon bah c est
laverie du
en tout cas apparents du système bédié
moi je suis plutôt satisfait que le
système bédié tombe parce que c'est un
système clientéliste et communautariste
qui a pourri les relations et les et la
façon de fonctionner ici sur mantes la
jolie leur est dorénavant au travail
pour dessiner les quatre prochaines
années de la ville ma petite expérience
politique fait que je sais très bien que
les soirs de victoire sont des soir
qu'il faut savourer parce que les
difficultés commencent dès lendemain
cette ville est une vie dans lequel on a
beaucoup de difficultés économiques
sociales éducatives et je sais que le
travail qui nous attend est immense mais
avec l'équipe que j'ai et la confiance
des habitants de mantes la jolie je suis
sûr qu'on va réussir mais il faut qu'on
soit tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]